[MUSIC PLAYING]
Jaampr is a social network
to connect the people
with activities around
them in real-time.
When we started, we didn't
have money or investment.
For this reason, we only can
work a few hours per day.
In this video, I want to
show you five libraries
to make your life happier.
The Android Social
Network Library
can help us to
find users faster.
We use a library to connect our
application with other social
networks like Twitter,
Facebook, LinkedIn, and Google+.
That is useful to import
friends or followers
for other social networks.
We wanted to
[INAUDIBLE] something,
but we didn't want
to lose our good look
and our good performance.
We didn't want to spend
time making graphic designs.
And we used Material
Design in our application
and still keep compatibility
with previous version
of Android Lollipop.
With a few lines of
code, we code activities.
We create socket connection
using a library of Socket.IO
for Android to create
faster connection
with our server in real-time.
We send requests
to our server using
Volley library and download
image with Picasso library.
With Volley library, we can
send objects, texts, and images
to our server.
And with Picasso library,
we can manage image caches
in our application.
With this library, we win more
time to develop our business.
What is really important--
launch prototype fast,
reuse code, and win
happier developers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]